just 20 minutes north of New York City
this is New Rochelle New York's governor
sealed off the city of 80,000 when more
than a hundred people contracted
coronavirus the highest cluster anywhere
in the u.s. scenes like out of a science
fiction movie
a drive-through testing station for
coronavirus the facility designed to
handle 200 cars a day has one huge
advantage over traditional testing
methods according to the New York's
governor it's actually safer to keep
them in their car so they can come in
for the testing it's less exposure
overall back in New York the city is
slowly grinding to a halt the
Metropolitan Museum of Art which hosts
millions of visitors a year is now
closed for those who rely on the crowds
for their livelihoods like the street
vendors out front it's been terrible
house business there is no business
museum is shut down there's no tourists
so we have to tough it out until it's
all over
have you ever seen business this bad
before
never but it's not just the met dozens
of cultural institutions throughout New
York City have been affected Museum of
Natural History the Whitney Museum the
New York City Opera and even Carnegie
Hall all are closed because of
coronavirus fears taxi drivers tell us
business has been slashed in half waited
four hours for a ride at the airport
every day but every driver minimum four
hours three hours may buy us some time
you various because there's no
passengers or what no besson's are no
pest the lights have gone off on
Broadway to some of the world's most
popular shows among those ordered to
closed for a month missing out on
millions of dollars in revenues
and there's also a scarcity the shelves
of the supermarket look like the streets
largely empty New Yorkers rush to stock
up fearing the worst of taking measures
to protect themselves
Gabriel's Ando al Jazeera New York